janna for anyone who knows nothing about
screenwriting how would you begin to
teach them the craft yeah that's a great
question because we all kind of start
from this place of not knowing
screenwriting unless you decide to go to
a film program that's actually teaching
screenwriting it's one of those things
that is not a part of our education
system or anything like that so a lot of
us are starting from scratch the great
thing about it being 2021 is that there
are resources everywhere so i actually
just got this question via email the
other day and my first response was just
start writing
right it's kind of like even if you are
doing creative writing if you have uh
short stories that you're interested in
if you want to be a journalist and you
want to write articles you just have to
start practicing it right so that's the
first thing that you can do is just
start writing down your ideas the other
thing you want to do is then figure out
how to hone that craft are there
screenwriting classes
anywhere
whether they're in your area or they are
virtual are there screenwriting groups
that are in your area or virtual or go
to youtube university right which is
what we were talking about earlier and
so there are a lot of different um
organizations that have pages like film
courage like my page that are teaching
the fundamentals of screenwriting
because the biggest thing is
understanding the format which always
tricks people up a lot trips people up a
lot and understanding the structure the
third thing you can do which is just an
addition to honing your craft is read
screenplays
but make sure that you are reading
actual screenplays and not transcripts
so a lot of the times when people will
google and look for a particular
screenplay the transcript will come up
and just so you know the difference the
transcript will be only dialogue and
it'll all be formatted left
and it'll just be you know the dialogue
from the screenplay because someone
actually um watched the film and just
wrote down what everyone was saying but
if you're going to be the screenwriter
you need to learn how they are
formatting the scene headings what
action looks like where everything is
placed so you want to make sure that
you're looking at the actual screenplay
and not the transcript when you're
looking at those screenplays ask
yourself what you like to write
ask yourself what you like to watch so
that you can then read screenplays that
fill in that format and that genre
because each genre is going to have kind
of their own rules and so you want to
make sure that you're learning how to
write the thing that you're interested
in
so what if someone says okay i've
already been working at writing a
screenplay i actually have four or five
at home but i live in a small town i
have a family i have a full-time job
i don't know what to do from here
yeah so the first thing you want to do
is get some feedback
on your screenplay um because this
industry is one where there are going to
be gatekeepers
that are going to be in place before you
can get to the big studios or the
networks or production companies so in
order for your screenplay to get made at
all someone is going to have to read it
and so you want to make sure that your
screenplay is in a great place and that
it's going to make it past the reader
right so a great way to do that is
finding people like myself as a script
consultant or finding script coverage
companies so that you can get another
set of eyes on those screenplays so it's
great if you have three or four
screenplays if you only have one keep
writing
you know get to your three or four right
and then send them out so that you can
get feedback on them to see if they are
up to industry standard to see if there
is an actual story there now from there
that's when it becomes tricky because
this is a who you know kind of industry
and if you are in whatever city outside
of you know los angeles new york atlanta
maybe then it may be a little harder to
figure out how you're going to get in so
some of the options that you have are
screenwriting competitions competitions
don't mean that you will automatically
get your screenplay made but it's about
exposure
and access right so if you pay attention
to
which screenwriting competitions are
going to have who on their jury
reading those screenplays then you want
to try to get in front of those people
so that they can help you to get into
the door the same thing is true for any
film festivals you can attend film
festivals and maybe meet some of the
producers who are there managers and
agents who are there to be able to talk
to them about your work don't have your
screenplay printed out and pass it to
anyone don't do it don't do it
keep your printed screenplay at home but
while you're there you want to be
networking and meeting people because
since this is a who you know kind of
industry then you need to get out there
and meet some folks right there are also
different kind of pitch competitions
that are out there that will also give
you an opportunity to pitch to people
who are in the industry who then may
help you to develop your work to take it
to the next place if you don't want to
do hollywood at all and you don't want
to deal with a big machine then raise
your own money hire your own people and
make your own content because there are
many ways for you to get your own
content out there now
so you said keep writing uh if if i just
have one or two screenplays what if my
life story is so fascinating i just have
to get this story you don't understand
shannon yeah i have to get this story
out yeah it's once you hear my life
story you will want to make this movie
too right
and i'm not looking to do other
other stories yeah if you're not looking
to do other stories if you don't want to
be a professional writer
i'm going to say kind of the same thing
applies to you because unless you're
going to find the money to make it
yourself you still got to get in to know
somebody to get them to make it so
you're still going to have to deal with
those gatekeepers so if your life story
is so fantastic and so many of us think
that it is right if your life story is
so fantastic then you need to find a
producer who you can prove to that
person that it's that fantastic someone
has to get interested enough in the
story so you want to be able to you know
have your log line ready have your pitch
ready have your screenplay ready
whatever materials you're going to have
to be able to show them like this is
something that you want to tell and if
they decide to buy it and develop it etc
then they will
but if you don't want to be a
professional writer you may say to
yourself but i don't want to go through
all those hoops i don't want to deal
with that i want it made now
raise some money
hire your people and make it yourself
because if it's the kind of story that
you just it's your baby and you just
want to make it then make it and air it
to your family air it in your hometown
air it in your city you can rent out a
theater
within the amc or whatever
theater you have in your community you
can rent out one of the rooms and show
it on the big screen and still have that
same experience if you're not trying to
become a professional writer so you just
have to ask yourself what do you want of
that project
realize what the different avenues are
and then choose one and hopefully we'll
get to see your story on the screen okay
what if you know i've heard a lot of bad
stuff about hollywood and and
i don't trust those people so
you know i i need you to get it out
there for me because i i just you know
i've been warned me as in me or is this
a general question it could be you it
could be it could be me going to
something but but we could i could
roleplay and say to you like i could you
know and so i i've heard stories and i
just don't trust it and i know that you
could navigate on my behalf right so
what you're looking for is someone to be
your representative those people are
managers those people are agents those
people are entertainment lawyers i'm a
script consultant so that's not my part
of the job my part is to get people from
idea to pitch your representatives then
get you into the room to be able to
pitch and then you're going to pitch to
executives or producers or even actors
or directors whoever it is you can get
in the room with so that it can get
bought developed and then made into uh
into your film or your television show
so you want to make sure whoever it is
you're approaching is the right person
so that means you have to start with
research because the thing about this
industry if you decide to go the
hollywood route the thing about this
industry is people care about you doing
your part and you doing the work so if
you were to approach someone who doesn't
do that thing but you're asking them for
that thing then they're going to
consider that this is not something that
you're serious about right so for
example not every production company or
every studio makes the same kind of
films or tv shows right so if this is a
faith based production company but you
want to make a a vampire comedy right
and so now you're pitching your vampire
comedy to this christian-based
production company then they know that
you have not done your research right
you don't understand their brand and now
that is going to look um bad on you
professionally right so if you don't
want to do that bidding yourself great
so that means you need to find someone
else who does that thing who is that go
between who is that liaison who can do
it for you so do the research to figure
out where the places that would make my
kind of movie or my kind of tv show
who are the people who i need to contact
who have made their stuff there right
because a lot of those studios are
working with the same kind of production
companies over and over again right so
then you figure out well who do i need
to have a relationship with to go there
so there's still going to be some work
on your part because if you don't know
anyone then you still have to find the
people in order for them to do the rest
of the work um so it's a tough part of
the industry which is why it's not
favorable for everyone it does take a
lot of work on your end and a lot of
grit on your end and even if you do have
a representative if you are trying to be
a professional writer even if you do
have a representative the work doesn't
stop for you there you know right so
they're out doing some bidding but
you're still going to get most of the
gigs because of the work that you're
doing yourself so if you're in a
position of saying that's not what i
want to do then maybe reconsider this
may not be the industry for you because
there's gonna have to be work done
on your end and you're gonna have to get
out of your comfort zone
okay and then lastly and and i love this
advice um i've given uh my work's
letting me take two weeks to come out to
la and i'm armed with like five scripts
um i've talked to a couple people on
social media who say they might want to
produce it for me executive produce it i
haven't found too much about them online
one of them says they have their own
company and they have money that they
can put behind it and they want to meet
so we're going to meet at a restaurant
and
we're going to talk about them helping
me make my project how do i know that i
could trust this person
well if you've done your research and
you haven't found anything you now have
to go with your gut
go to the meeting
listen
learn don't over share don't sign
anything
right consider this a part of your
research
when you're there
do you want them to take care of your
baby
right that's what this conversation is
about everyone starts from somewhere so
maybe they are new in the producing
field so there isn't much online about
them just like you're new in the writing
field right so it's not to say that just
because you can't find anything about
them online means you shouldn't work
with them maybe maybe not you may say
okay well we're both starting out so we
could be starting this relationship
together as issa ray said you want to
network this way right and not this way
so if both of you are starting in the
same place take the meeting see what
happens but while you're in that meeting
listen to yourself
listen to them and then make decisions
from there it may work out
it may not
right but that's going to happen no
matter who you decide to work with now
if you do see a lot of negative stuff
online then don't take the meeting
there's no reason to take the meeting if
you can't find anything then take the
meeting and just listen learn have your
questions ready ask yourself what do i
need to know in order for me to feel
comfortable with doing this and then
when you're in that meeting ask those
questions a lot of the times what
happens is the writer always feels like
the person on the you know lowest end of
the totem pole which may or may not be
true so when we get into meetings with
other people we automatically get into
uh our own shells and think that we
don't have a voice to be able to request
what we need right but if this is your
baby and these people say they're
interested then you're interviewing them
as much as they're interviewing you
right so when you're there ask the
questions and if you don't get the
information that you need that makes you
feel comfortable with having a
relationship with them then you have all
the information you need shake hands
don't burn bridges right shake hands say
thank you and then find someone who is
the best for your project
and i like that so
issa ray said uh network like this yeah
network horizontally instead of
vertically she may not have used those
words but that's what she meant
i don't remember the actual quote yeah
okay and sorry and so that means then
don't try to like be like this social
climber like do it with people that are
starting out at your level as well yeah
it basically means the people who you're
starting out with are all moving at the
same time right so that means one of
those people is going to be in a
position
that can help you at some point just
like you might be in a position that can
help them so make friends with these
people if we're all assistants at the
same time we're probably all going to be
executives at the same time or one of
them will become an executive and i'll
become a writer or another person
becomes a director and now going back to
that who you know thing
right now i'm working with the people
that i know because we started off
together versus everyone wants to get
into the room and they want to talk to
steven spielberg right
talk to steven spielsberg's assistant
first of all that's the closest person
to him right but secondly that person
has aspirations too you know most
assistants there's nothing wrong with
wanting to be a lifelong assistant we
need people who are very organized and
get things done but most assistants are
there because they're trying to get
somewhere else and that's just the path
that they chose to get experience right
so that person may want to become an
agent that person may want to be a
manager that person may want to be a
director if you get a relationship with
them because both of you are in a place
where you can build a relationship in
the first place because you're not going
to get to steven spielberg and make a
relationship just because you're on set
one day right but if you're nice to the
assistant and you guys become cool then
now you start rising together and you
have the people that you need when it's
time to take a meeting you can call over
to this place because you know the
person that's working there because you
guys were both pas on some you know
random music video five years ago you
know so i think it's really important as
she said to make sure that you don't
ignore these people just because they
haven't made it yet because some of them
will maybe you will maybe you won't
right but instead of jumping over those
people and going to the people who are
already in place who don't have time for
you let's just be honest right they
don't have that kind of time
so instead of trying to jump to those
people pay attention to the people who
are grinding at the same time that you
are
so we touched on some excellent points
the right way to start screenwriting
let's talk about the wrong way to start
oh that's the question yeah that's a
question
sorry i think this offshore no it's okay
okay i think the wrong way to start is
just assuming you know how this thing
works
right assuming that you know what
screenwriting is and so you don't have
to do any research that you don't have
to um try to hone your craft in any way
that you don't have to read any
screenplays that you can just wake up
and write right and even though i said
earlier
writing is a part of it right that's the
first thing you want to do you want to
start getting your ideas out to see what
they are right but then to assume that
that's all it takes is the wrong place
to start um it's also the wrong place to
start to assume that you don't have to
know anything about the business right
as writers you're your own advocate you
are your business and you're walking
into a business so as much as it's
creative there's also the business part
of it and so you can have the best
screenplays out there but if you don't
know how to play this game of getting
into the business then you're not going
to be in the right mindset of it um
and also
assuming that you're just gonna be able
to jump right in right like there is
like there's no uh
putting in the midnight oil you know
what i mean of realizing that this is a
long game
this hollywood thing is long game so
going back to that networking across
thing right
five years from now 10 years from now
all of those people are gonna be in
different places not two days from now
so the same thing is true with your
writing it's a process so going back to
knowing the business realizing that i
can write a screenplay today and it
might not get made until seven years
from now
right so realizing that it's not a quick
thing it's not an in and out
you know kind of machine which is why
you have to ask yourself what is it that
i want from this what is my end goal am
i trying to be a professional writer am
i just trying to get this one thing done
and if it's only that one thing do i
really want to put the time and energy
into doing it
another place that you shouldn't start
from is thinking that the writer has
total creative control
right this is a collaborative effort
filmmaking is so realizing that there
will always be someone critiquing your
work always always always always and
then learning how to separate yourself
from that so you aren't taking taking it
personally a no to your work is not a no
to you as a person like take that in
you know breathe it
understand it that no to your work may
mean this is not the right work for our
company it may mean this is not what
we're looking for right now it may mean
there's growth necessary on your part
that's good information to hear you want
to hear great i need to grow because now
you know what to you know what to work
towards versus not hearing anything at
all because that happens in hollywood
too where people just don't respond to
you at all you don't get anything right
but getting that no tells you
i now am open to try to sell this
somewhere else this wasn't the right fit
for it and getting that information so
i know a lot of people uh say you need
tough skin when you come into this
this industry and yes that may be true
but if you can learn how to disconnect
from your work equaling your worth
right
then the tough skin is not necessary as
much because you know that they're not
critiquing you
right they're talking about what's on
the page and when someone else develops
it or someone else purchases it they're
now trying to get it to fit the mold of
their brand which is why you have to do
your research at the first place to ask
yourself is this the best place for my
baby is this the best place for my story
right if you decide to pitch something
to nbc it's got to feel like nbc
so that means the executives are going
to mold it into
nbc that means they might lose trim some
of the stuff that you think is very
important it may mean that they're going
to add some stuff that you never thought
about that's going to make this the best
show to ever hit television so you have
to be open to that collaborative process
so i think those three or four things
are really important that if you're not
understanding that you're starting off
in the wrong place
can you have
thick skin
tough skin
and not be callous
yes i think so um
i think that thick skin that people are
talking about is being able to receive
feedback not take it personally and then
therefore not react from an emotional
place and start to burn bridges
with that being said there are plenty of
callous people in the industry
a lot of the people who tell people they
need to have tough skin don't have tough
skin themselves
right uh everyone is sensitive you know
and in the world that we live in right
now everyone is sensitive and then you
come into an industry where um
we are creating things and like erica
badu said people are sensitive about
their stuff right so
i think that thick skin just really
comes from a place of understanding that
this is not about you and it's about the
work and the stuff but you are going to
deal with all kinds of different
personalities just like you would in any
kind of industry there are people who
are not so nice here right there are
people who are rude here and then there
are people who aren't and there are
people who want to help you and there
are people who want you to grow but at
the end of the day you're still going to
hear no more than more than you hear yes
right someone does have to approve and
accept and affirm the thing that you're
giving to them and oftentimes you're not
going to hear the thing you wanted to
hear and if you don't know how to
disconnect if you don't know how to grow
that tough skin that they say then it
can start to chip away at who you are
right um and that should not be
the end goal so yeah i think you can
definitely have tough skin and not end
up being a callous person but it takes
work
you know it takes work
and then you also said
not knowing the industry so if i want to
jump in one of the wrong ways is to not
do research on the industry and who i'm
pitching and different things like that
what if i say you know what i'm just
really good at winging it i've always
been good at sports i can fit into any
room i'm a chameleon in some ways i
don't really need i can just just get me
there and and i'll know who's in charge
yeah i have a radar for that do it
try it out because at the end of the day
no one has the same true hollywood story
right everyone gets into this industry
in a different way
so if that's your strong suit
getting into the room and selling
yourself the hard part is getting into
the room
right when you get in there let your
personality shine you know do the thing
that works for you because nine times
out of ten if that works for you in
other places it'll work for you here as
long as whatever it is you're saying can
actually be backed up by what's on the
page a lot of people think what's on the
page is fantastic and wonderful and it
just isn't right so now you went into
the room and you oversold
right you went into the room and you
said i have this thing and then we read
this thing and it's like
no you don't right so making sure that
you're not going to oversell because now
people are going to remember that you
may not be able to get into the room the
next time but other than that if you're
a winged kind of person wing it the
question is how do you get in the room
in the first place in order to wing it
that's why you have to know about the
industry
do you ever see that where someone who's
kind of under confident they actually
have really excellent work yeah and it's
the ones that are like beating the the
chest and wait you just gotta see and
it's like might not be there yet almost
always
it's almost always that and i say almost
because there are outliers but it's
almost always that usually the people
you know the more introverted more i'm
not really sure you know what's
happening here you read their stuff and
it's like you got something here you can
be confident about that and then it's
the people who say i know i have this
thing you read it and it's like you
don't know how to format a scene heading
so no you don't have this thing you know
quite yet so yes it happens all the time
and this is not necessarily an industry
that expects people to be humble you
know what i mean so i don't i don't
my i don't mock them for being
overconfident
however
that thing on the page is what
represents you period it doesn't matter
what's coming out of your mouth you know
what i mean so you have to be able to
back it up which is why i said earlier
you need that other set of eyes you need
someone you can trust on your team as a
script consultant that's what i become i
become a part of your team everybody
needs a script consultant even if they
don't know that we exist right but once
you find someone you need someone who
can objectively look at your stuff and
let you know if you're doing the thing
you intend to do
good or bad right and if we don't have
those checks and balances then all we
have is our own confidence all we have
is our own ego and you can sometimes
oversell um what you have going on but i
don't think your overconfidence is bad
you know what i mean you know i would
rather that than you falling apart
because you get a no you know what i
mean but really trying to make sure that
whatever it is you're selling can be
seen on the page is the most important
thing there are plenty of people walking
around hollywood with egos we we have a
lot of those so i'm not going to say you
can't have an ego sure you can you know
what i mean but you got to be able to
back it up well what if i said though
you know what i ran this by my
brother-in-law and he owns his own
company and this guy he knows his stuff
so
it's already good i already know that
yeah does he know screenwriting
no but he's built a business and he's
very successful look at the end of the
day i'm always going to say try it
try it go with it send your screenplay
to one of these script coverage
companies send your screenplay to me
send it to a competition send it to a
film festival and see what happens right
because maybe you're right i'm not going
to say that you don't have natural
talent i have natural talent right i've
sent screenplays out that haven't been
looked at you know by other people and
they've done decently well so i can't
say that that won't happen for another
person but at the end of the day you
want someone who understands not only
the industry but also understands uh
writing you know understands the medium
of screenplays so that they can give you
actual criticism and critique if not
then it's just opinion right like you
can have your mom or your dad or your
brother read as much as you want they'll
like it or don't won't like it but can
they tell you why can they tell you how
to fix things or are they just giving
more opinion and everybody out there has
got an opinion it doesn't mean that it's
going to make your story better so if
you feel that you don't need another set
of eyes totally fine put it out in the
into the universe and see if you get
what you need in return and if you don't
then you'll have to change your tactic
just like your characters have to do you
know when they aren't getting the things
that they need
are there any other best practices
that'll help someone get their start i
think
those
first few of
knowing who you are as a writer
what you like to write
what your end goal is
um
and then
honing in on that to me and then
obviously figuring out the business
figuring out the business is the hardest
part because just like there's no formal
education on screenwriting unless you're
in film school there's no formal
education on the business like you can
even go to film school and not learn the
business right that part's going to be
more trial and error
but as far as those other things those
are kind of the best practices get out
there try and try again you know in the
beginning stages
write all kinds of stuff and see what
you enjoy um something that i ask my
students is what do you like to watch
what do you like to write because a lot
of the times those two things don't add
up
and so if you know that going forward i
mean from from the beginning then now
you can make sure that your uh your
samples your materials actually add up
to what you want to do because if you're
out in the world saying oh yeah i love
watching one-hour dramas but you're
writing half-hour comedies right
then are you saying that you want to
work in dramas but for whatever reason
you've been writing comedies or do you
actually want to write in comedies and
so now you know i should be reading
those comedy scripts instead of those
one-hour drama scripts even though i
like watching those one-hour drama
scripts so really just trying to figure
out who you are as a writer
what your end goal is so that you can
start working your way there and then
once you're in a little more you can
start concerning yourself with getting
representatives and getting all that
other kind of stuff but it really just
starts with the craft and also
understanding that everybody out there
is just trying no one has the answer
right everybody's um journey into this
uh hollywood machine is different if you
decide to go independent it's going to
be different because you're doing it on
your own so just having the confidence
to say if i've decided that i'm going to
sign up for this then i'm just going to
do it and i'm just going to roll with
the punches how they come
are there any false beliefs that new
writers have that sometimes just drive
you crazy hmm false beliefs
i think one of the biggest ones is that
they think it'll happen overnight you
know they think well i have this idea
and it really has to be on tv by next
year because what's happening right now
you know is is uh is so important that
this story has to be told and i can tell
them i agree with you
the industry just doesn't work that way
all right it just takes time so i think
that's one of the biggest ones is just
not realizing how much time it takes to
do things um
i'm trying to think are there any other
false beliefs that people have
i think that's the biggest one
yeah okay so i mean let's suppose let's
say i watched um
startup or queen's gambit or one of
these excellent series and i want to do
i have this great idea that it's going
to be very similar
is that its own mistake because it's
already been done and it's already been
done so well why try to not necessarily
not necessarily in my opinion there are
no new ideas
uh especially now hollywood is big on
reboots and remakes right so they're big
on established ip period
so if it's already been done the
question is what are you going to do
that makes it unique what's going to
make it different you make it different
first of all because your experience in
this world is different so if you decide
to tell a story about a kid who doesn't
know who his parents are and lives uh
with his aunt and uncle who are
emotionally abusive it doesn't mean that
it turns into harry potter right but
it's still got the same premise that
this child is looking for identity right
so it's okay if you've seen it
um you just have to figure out what
unique thing you're bringing to the
table the other thing is trying to
follow the trends of hollywood some
people are into trends some people want
to write what they are already seeing on
television because they think that's
what's being purchased i'm here to tell
you if you're watching it the trend has
passed
right in hollywood the trends pass every
few months right so whatever that
production company studio network or
streamer was looking for in january
they're not looking for that same thing
by june so if right now you're seeing
vampires on every network and you're
working on a vampire pilot right now in
your house doesn't mean don't write it
but it does mean that by the time you're
able to pitch it to someone we're not
into vampires anymore we've moved on so
i tell people you know you have to
decide if you're going to follow the
trends or not that can be a good thing
for you if you're already a professional
writer and you're already in the game
therefore you hear about the trend
before the trend starts so that yes you
want to be writing the thing that you
know that they're looking for because
all of those studios etc have mandates
and so they can say at whatever part of
the year we're looking for vampire
stories where you're ahead of the game
go write a vampire story but if you are
just starting out and you're seeing all
the vampire stories on tv or on the big
screen then that trend has already
passed so then now it comes to maybe i
should just write what i'm interested in
period and when it becomes something
people want to read great or like i've
said before
sometimes it's not about selling
something and it's about having it as a
sample to show how great of a writer you
are because if you can write vampires
i'm going to assume you can write ghost
i'm going to assume you can write
werewolves i'm going to assume that you
can write in this science fiction
fantasy you know world or maybe horror
whatever it is uh whatever kind of story
it was so you can still use that as a
sample to get you into the next thing it
may not get purchased and if you want to
be a professional writer then i think
it's a great balance to look at anything
you write as a possible sample versus i
have to sell it
because you don't have control over what
happens on the other side unless you're
doing it independently so if you write
somethings i have to sell this then now
you're setting yourself up for
disappointment if you don't versus
saying i'm writing a fantastic sample
and i'm going to show this to someone
and those people might like it and they
might decide they want to buy it now
when
right now you have a win um but yeah i
would say just
focus on writing what you like to write
um that's what makes it fun if it's not
going to be fun we could all be doing
something else right we can all be uh
we're we took on this creative job
because it's supposed to be fun if it's
not gonna be fun then we could be doing
whatever job someone else tried to push
us into
what if i say well i'm gonna resurrect
an old show like the office but we're
gonna all be on zoom
or or facebook live or google chat and
we're gonna just it's gonna be so cool
and it'll be the same office politics
but now we're all virtual and our bosses
are spying on us at home yeah so it'll
be really cool and it's been a few years
since the show was on so i can resurrect
it right maybe
right if someone out there is interested
in it if someone out there is looking
for something like it like i said before
hollywood is kind of interested in
established i.p at this point and not to
say that you would then have to get in
touch with the people who made the
office and blah blah blah have to be
different enough because if it's the
same thing then now you're infringing on
their copyright
right so you're not necessarily making
the office unless you are right there
are a lot of reboots that are being made
right now and they're making uh bel air
which is a reboot of the fresh prince of
bel air right with the entirely
different group of people but that means
that they went through the proper
channels to make sure that there's no
infringement etc etc so they can do that
so instead of saying you're making the
office make something that is new and
original and say that it's like the
office right unless of course you have
the permission to be making the office
and doing it you know doing something
different with it but you know again
like i said there in my opinion there
aren't any new ideas i've had people
pitch me the same idea in three
different states from three different
people and one of those pers people
wasn't even a writer
and i was just like wow this is crazy
how we're all living in the same world
right now so we're all getting the same
information and that's
making a lot of us create the same ideas
if that makes sense um so if there was
something about the office that you
enjoyed ask yourself
what was it about the office that i
enjoyed
maybe that's the thing that you take
and turn into your own thing because the
office doesn't own office politics right
if any of us have ever worked in a
corporate space then we know office
politics right so the people who made
the office don't own that space what
they did to make it different was the
way they filmed it the mockumentary
style et cetera et cetera but other than
that it's all the same stuff that we'd
see in any other kind of office right um
so asking yourself what is it that i
liked from that and then how can i put
that into this idea that i have that's
about zoom or about whatever it is so
that it i'm turning it on its head so
that there's something unique about it
and now i can utilize the office as
proof that this may work but i'm not
necessarily selling you the office uh so
maybe like pam she was yeah okay so
let's say pam's character type let's see
she was the go-to gal and she knew where
all the staples were and you know and
everybody kind of needed her all at once
so i'm going to make a series sort of
like based on her life but it's she's
going to be at home but it's not really
taking
the office's ip it's just a kind of a
caricature
exactly someone like pam if you decide
to make it pam then now you're
infringing
but if you do something like pam because
again pam exists because that person
exists in all offices there's always
somebody who knows where everything is
you know that maybe that's the
coordinator maybe it's um uh the admin
uh the uh
the ceo's a administrative assistant or
whoever it is but somebody in that
office everybody knows i'm going to go
ask her she's going to be able to get it
to me and ask him he's going to be able
to get it so that's not a new idea
right so being able to say well that's
what i thought was interesting this
particular character knowing everything
about the office right so then you have
to then of course build your story from
there because that's a character that's
not enough to get you a story or a pilot
or a series but understanding that
that's the thing that you're pulling
from then that can work for you
so pam's a remote worker but she has
another job on the side that her boss
doesn't know about and she's doing it on
company time and it's a little bit more
nefarious
and so she's gotta make sure that she's
on point for the office but then she's
doing i don't know she's taking adult
surveys or she's doing something that's
like it's not horrible but it's like
whoa you know pam what are you doing
right right right so the balance of that
will then be what the series is about
and then figuring out what the stakes
are that she is doing that like does she
has she signed some kind of clause in
her everyday job that says that she
shouldn't be or can't be doing this
thing so that if they find out that
she's doing this thing then this thing
is in jeopardy
right so you have to ask yourself you
know what is the story right someone
doing those two things okay cool but
what do they have to do with each other
how do they you know crash into each
other to cause a problem like does she
have a problem trying to balance the two
you know or what does it become so you
still have to then build out the entire
story around pam or you know the
pam-like character to see what it's
going to become
what is screenplay structure
very big question right um but
i would look at screenplay structure as
how you tell a story
and depending upon the kind of
screenplay you're writing the structure
is different
in general we've all learned about
three-act structure in some way shape or
form
that three-act structure can then be
broken down into just two acts if you're
writing a half-hour multi-camera comedy
it can be spread out into four or five
or six acts if you're doing a one hour
drama but your half hour single camera
and your features are usually told in
three acts and if you want to break it
down and make it as simple as possible
your first act is your setup
it's giving me all the information i
need to know of why i am here
your second act is the journey to reach
the goal
and then your third act is
what happened now that i reached the
goal right so it's your resolution so
you have your setup your journey and
your resolution and so if you can
understand that anytime we hear a story
bedtime story
dr seuss what happened last weekend
we're all listening for the setup
the journey to success or failure and
then what happened after that so to me
that's like the simplest way of talking
about what structure is for a screenplay
i like how you broke that down because
when we think about let's say a family
friend or a bunch of friends getting
together telling a story about what
happened last weekend
it makes sense if they leave out
the second act that's but when we think
about a story that we're writing
we could i could see where things would
get convoluted yeah because you also
even if you don't understand story
structure
you feel it
so you have a cousin or a friend who
doesn't know how to tell stories right
so they come in and they go oh let me
tell you what happened last weekend and
you know that this particular cousin or
friend is just going to talk on and on
and on and on and never get to the point
of what happened right but amongst your
friend friend group are amongst your
family they're like no no no let such
and such tell it
because you know such and such is going
to give you the setup
the journey
and what happened you know the
resolution you know that you're going to
get there you know that they're going to
give you the details that you need
nothing extraneous or they're going to
say quick sidebar and then they'll give
you this extraneous stuff and then
they'll come back to the story and keep
you following the journey right so
storytelling is storytelling and
storytelling no matter where you're
telling it right um in a screenplay it
has to be more concise and it has to be
visual
but even those people who don't
specifically know they can't give you
the vocabulary they don't have the words
to explain
you know how to tell a story we're
hearing people tell stories all the time
you know like going back to that office
thing there's somebody in your office
who always stands around the kitchen or
whatever and they have a story
you know blah blah blah and you enjoy
their stories and then there's somebody
else who always has a story and you're
trying to sneak away from the
conversation because you know you're
going to be here for the next 15 minutes
and have learned
absolutely nothing and so that's kind of
how you know that your screenplay isn't
working because we're 30 pages in and i
don't have i don't have any information
we're 30 pages in and i don't know what
this screenplay is about we're 30 pages
in and i don't know why i've been
dropped into it right i don't know what
i'm here to witness because there's a
whole lot of talking and going around
the you know bend and over the river and
through the woods but i still having the
slightest idea what my protagonist is
trying to do or possibly who my
protagonist is in the first place
right so sometimes that happens um but
yeah storytelling is storytelling so if
we start to
allow and it's hard when you're the
writer right when it's on the page
because now there's all kind of pressure
and stress and stuff but if we allow
ourselves to step away from it and just
look at it like any kind of story we can
ask ourselves like does it feel like my
story is moving forward or does it feel
like people are just kind of talking
around
some things you know but that's why
again people like me exist because maybe
you can't see that yourself and i pride
myself on being objective my students
tell me all the time your objective
right i even had a student in one of my
classes on the university level said can
you teach the rest of our teachers how
to be objective in this way because when
i read their stuff i don't
make them become a particular kind of
writer
i'm able to look at them as individuals
which means they write the way that they
write it's not my job to make them fit
into this box right but a lot of the
times you may send your work out and
what you receive back is a whole lot of
opinion about what your writing should
be and you should change this and it
should be this you should have that blah
blah blah and it's like well that's a
great story but that's not my story
that's not the one that i'm trying to
tell right so finding someone else who
can objectively look at your stuff they
can help to help you to understand that
your story is kind of going around in
circles and not pushing forward just
like when uncle such and such starts
telling a story you know whether it's a
drunken one or not right you know he's
never going to get to the point guys we
can go continue playing our basketball
game right so when you say that um
you like to to work with people and and
find out the way they tell a story and
who they are
um
how like how is that because because so
somebody could say well this is just who
i am and i i don't really like to
formulate full sentences and i'm just
this is just my style yeah
is that acceptable if it's working
okay that's why you have to be objective
because sure
we can say i need full sentences
but if it's working if the fact that
they're
shortening their sentences is helping me
to feel
the tone that they're setting helping me
to feel the urgency of the story i read
a screenplay the other day
and every single line of action was just
one sentence
but it made the story simple because it
was about a simple guy doing a simple
thing i didn't need more
right
but if this were a more
convoluted premise if it were a more
dramatic story where i needed to feel
more things etc then now my note would
be i need more right and here is why but
i was able to tell this particular
writer
usually i would say i need x y and z but
this is working for you
because i also want them to know the
rule
right i also want them to know someone
else might read this and say x y and z
but it's working for you the same thing
is true with um
i sometimes have people who instill
their voice too much as a writer and so
it's jarring right now i'm hearing you
and it's pulling me out of the story
sometimes that works though
same thing with camera angles right it's
a no-no for writers to infuse camera
angles in their screenplay because it's
distracting to the reed i'm into
something emotional then here you come
with big capital letters close in i
already know that i'm close
because i feel it because i'm reading
the story and now you just ruined it for
me by yelling close in as if the
director won't feel that from the
context that you've set up but then i
read somebody else's screenplay and they
didn't use it a lot but the moments that
they did
worked
it felt right it didn't pull me out so
that's what i mean by you have to be
objective to the story
you have to understand what is this
story trying to do what does it feel
like what's its tone what's its writer's
voice what is it intending to do and are
they doing that and if they are then why
would i tell them to take away the
things that are making that thing happen
you know
so if we took let's say a young charles
bukowski in a writing program
and you know there's just one way to do
this and then he's presenting this work
that
might be you know might raise some
eyebrows but that's who he was that's
his style
and and maybe he just didn't find the
right teacher
yeah i mean
and you know the thing is not everyone's
a teacher
just because you know how to write
doesn't mean you know how to teach
people how to write that's just the
truth of it and i think we take the
whole we take the education part of it
uh
um
not seriously enough right um so maybe
that is the case because also teachers
are only teaching what they've been
taught depending upon how much
experience you've had in the industry
you may think it has to be this way
because i was taught it has to be this
way but if you're continuing to read
screenplays even as a professional
writer you'll see that people break
rules all the time people are doing
stuff all the time people make terrible
stuff that makes it onto tv and onto the
big screen all the time so why would i
tell my client that wouldn't work
you can't do that it's just not true you
can do anything you want now i'm going
to tell you what the industry standard
looks like i'm going to tell you what
people expect
but do you
because maybe it's going gonna work now
there are some things that you just
can't do like if it's if it's unreadable
then it's not gonna work you know what i
mean if i can't follow the story because
of
whatever risk you're taking or creative
licenses you're taking then it's just
not going to work but if i can follow
the story and i understand the story a
lot of those rules really do fly out of
the window they really do i'm going to
teach you what those rules are but again
if it's working then i'm not going to
stop you from doing the thing that's
working think about aaron sorkin and how
much dialogue are in his screenplays
we're told all the time you can't have
that much dialogue you can't have that
much dialogue think about shonda rhimes
and how many monologues she has in her
screenplays and we're told all the time
can't have monologues can't have
monologues where here are two examples
where it's working
very well
for these two people so i just don't
believe in
the extremes i don't believe in yes this
is going to work and no that's not going
to work because hollywood lives like in
that in-between space and i think the
reason i can give that information is
because i have the experience to know
um and then also because i am a teacher
so i am trying to teach you to fish and
not giving you fish right so i'm always
going to give you the why the how the
possibilities the what-ifs and sometimes
that doesn't work for people because
they need to know exactly what it is but
i try to explain to them hollywood is
not one of those places not black or
white it really isn't it's all that
stuff in between so you're trying to
write a story
that is well executed that's that's
doing what you intended to do that
you're gonna be proud of that represents
you as a writer because all of us are
gonna look back on something that we
wrote and go oh my god that's terrible
oh i can't believe i wrote that so
you're gonna grow from it anyway so you
just have to get to a place where you're
happy with it
and it represents you so for someone
like aaron sorkin or even tarantito i'm
sure there were people telling them this
is too much dialogue i'm sure of it but
they were able to get in with whichever
way they got in because i don't know
their stories right but however it is
they got in and it worked out for them
how is screenplay structure different
from outlining a screenplay
oh i actually don't think it's different
at all um your structure should be there
from the beginning and if you're
outlining from the beginning you should
be able to follow your structure there
to me the biggest difference is
in my opinion i look at a beat sheet
like one-liners of your biggest moments
and then i look at an outline of
fleshing that out so that now you know
exactly what's happening in every single
scene
not necessarily just those big beats
even though for some people that's all
they need but now you start to see the
connecting beats that get you from the
large beats to the next large beats and
then the screenplay is actually the
creative part of writing out the scene
right so that's how i explain it to my
students
some people don't make beat sheets some
people just make outlines some people
don't make outlines and they just make
beat sheets and some people just write
the screenplay you have to figure out
what's best for your process in my
opinion you want to do some work before
you get to that screenplay because the
white page is intimidating
and if you don't know where you're going
it will eat you alive
right so just like with your google maps
you got to put in the address and know
what you're following even if you decide
okay i'm going to shut it off now i kind
of know where i'm going i don't have to
keep looking at my gps great same thing
for your beat sheet or your outline um
so for me i usually use the pixar
formula as my beat sheet
i love the pixar formula if you're
looking for one you can go google it now
i've added some things to my pixar
formula for my students because there's
some more emotional work i want them to
do
before they you know get past this point
but basically it asks you about the beat
sheets uh not the beat sheets the big
beats uh starting at once upon a time
and um now you have this
layout of what your story is that you
can post next to your computer or
wherever it is you want to put it so
that you always know where you're going
because as creatives we will veer off
the road and that's how we end up with
uncle such and such a story that never
makes it back to where it's supposed to
be
so if you have your
outline or your b sheet or your pixar
formula or whatever it is that you're
using you always have something to come
back to to go oh yeah because you also
have you know another uncle who's like
where was i what part was i on blah blah
blah blah well now you don't have to ask
anyone it's right here you've written it
down you know where you're going and
because every scene is supposed to be
cause and effect what happens in this
scene is because of what happened in
that scene then
looking at that beat sheet lets you know
these are the scenes that i need to get
to the next beat
and these are the scenes that i need to
get to the next beat because you know
that the point is i need to get from a
to b to c to d to e you know whatever
for some people they only need to know a
g
m
and z
right
i need to know a through z so my
outlines are a long you know my outlines
can be 60 pages long if i'm writing a
feature and if it's like i did one um
and i want to say it was somewhere
between 30 and 50 pages long because it
was a feature and it was science fiction
so there was a lot of stuff and rules
that you have to figure out if you don't
know the answers to those questions you
don't want to get to the page because
then you can kind of get lost in the
sauce but you know some people don't
need everything written out i like it
all to be written out because i also do
my revising in the outline
so as i start writing the screenplay and
new things do come because the outline
doesn't have to make it's not in
concrete right so new things do come oh
that's great that's good what you now
have to realize though is that new thing
is going to affect
the outline what's coming next maybe
what came before it so now you can go
back to the outline and go okay i got
this new thing so let me move this copy
and paste move that around blah blah
blah and now you can see what the new
story looks like without having to do it
in the screenplay which takes a lot
longer believe me i've done it right so
i utilize my outline throughout the
entire process which is why it's so much
longer but back to your original
question the structure is there that's
why you're outlining structure needs to
be there if you're outlining and there
is no structure your screenplay won't
have any structure
so the outline tells you what you know
and what you don't know if you're
outlining correctly i'm actually in the
middle of teaching my outlining class
right now it's called idea to story 2.0
i have it online for people to purchase
to do it at their own pace but then i do
it once a year where you get me live and
so we're now going through all of those
moments because i feel that if you have
a an effective outline then you will
write your screenplay far more
efficiently and so i give them workbooks
and worksheets that they can do
throughout that they can do with any
project they're doing but mostly so they
can eventually figure out what their
process is because they all may decide i
don't need this worksheet i don't need
that i don't need to do this outline but
if i do this thing this is the thing
that i need that helps everything to
open up so i'm just trying to help them
to figure out what their process is
while teaching them structure and then
hoping that they decide to do outlines
forever but they may not
so that's kind of a go uh go at your own
pace you said i have two two characters
right so the first idea of the story is
go at your own pace um you get all of
the videos all the worksheets et cetera
and you can just watch them on your own
and you know figure it out as you go and
if you have any questions then you can
sign up for kind of like an office hour
thing with me and then i'll kind of talk
you through your homework if you sign up
for the live version which i only do
once a year then we spend
two or three hours of lecture every week
and then 45 minutes to an hour of just
one-on-one talking about your story
because
if you take a screenwriting class a lot
of the times you're in taking the
general information but you're not
translating it to your story
so the only way that i know that they
actually learned what social proof was
is if i start talking to them about
their characters and social proof i only
know if they really understand an
inciting incident if i'm talking to them
about their inciting incident and what
information we got in during the normal
before the inciting incident so on and
so forth and so i think people enjoy
that part because then they start to
realize oh yeah i don't i don't know
right and it's like yeah so you can't go
to the blank page yet because you don't
know but learning that you don't know is
just as helpful because now you know
what holes need to be filled before you
get to the page
when a writer is outlining a screenplay
does that mean they are creating
structure at the same time yes exactly
that's exactly what that means they
should be looking to understand what
scenes make up my normal and when i say
normal that means the everyday life of
these characters whether the cameras
showed up or not like we're all living
our normal lives every day so your
characters are people who are doing
whatever it is they do
for an action film that means we're
probably going to open
in action because in their normal lives
they're already a police officer
firefighter ex-military whatever it is
they are right
um
so now you're asking yourself in the
outline what scenes am i using to show
my character's normal life right until
we get to the inciting incident which is
the thing that's going to crash into
that normal life create change therefore
causing a goal or a problem so you have
to ask yourself what do those scenes
look like what's that sequence of the
inciting incident what is the inciting
incident how does it make my
protagonists feel you know all of these
great questions and then you're going to
start to figure out well what is the
debate
is there a debate do they have to decide
to go on this journey or is it so urgent
that no matter what they're going on the
journey then you have to fix so you have
to figure out what do those scenes look
like right because you know that that
there being a debate
what's the debate who are they debating
with where are they debating why are
they debating right you get to figure
all of that out so the same is true
throughout the entire screenplay but in
the outline you're putting in all of the
structure all of those big beats but
asking yourself what are the scenes how
do i visually show this beat because a
million people can probably tell you the
inciting incident is a car crash
great where were they going what were
they doing who else is in the car where
did the car crash happen you know did
the ambulance come or did they stay
there by themselves and you know pass
away or did you know they end up getting
out did random people on the side of the
road come pull them out like what is the
scene
right and so in the outline you get to
start asking yourself what those scenes
are and putting them down not in um
you know
screenplay format you know but just the
information of
they were driving their child to the
nursery when they got hit by a a semi
auto semi truck whatever that came
through the light and
then we cut to the jaws of life getting
them out
that's the information you need in your
outline so that when you get to your
screenplay you can write it all
beautifully you know however it is
you're going to write it
well if we take something maybe that's
less dramatic so if we go back to our
sort of metaphorical pam character who's
like this office administrator everybody
needs her now she's remote working
her phone is buzzing all the time she
has no separation between her job and
her her life
but then maybe the inciting incident
because she's going to find this other
job which she'll moonlight
during office hours and they won't know
it because she'll have a second computer
maybe she meets a woman in a store
and they just have a fun exchange
talking and she says
what do you do and she says oh i'm you
know an office administrator and the
other woman does these surveys right and
she's kind of fascinating there's
something a little
interesting about her so she goes hey
give me your email and all so then maybe
that's where
and she sees this woman and she's kind
of intrigued by her because she she's
just different pam always does the right
thing
and this woman's a little bit rebellious
a little bit interesting and maybe
that's the the incident yeah it's not
the jaws of life
but it's something yeah something is
changing her normal her normal is i'm
working at home from zoom
every single day i'm answering the calls
and i gotta get dressed from here up so
that i can be present when they need me
blah blah blah blah today for lunch i
decided to go for a walk
and while i'm on that walk because i go
into the store to buy my lunch or
whatever i meet this person
that person just changed her life
so that's the inciting incident and that
small information is what's in your
outline
then you'll flesh that out to actually
be you know full scenes and however it
is you describe them in the action and
the dialogue and blah blah that's the
screenplay but in the outline you say
pam's working from her desk all the time
she's dressed from here on up blah blah
blah she's always answering the phone
and today she decided to go for a walk
for lunch and she bumps into
insert person right right that's what
you would have in your outline okay so
that would be the inciting incident if
it wasn't as dramatic where there was a
full action yeah the inciting incident
can be the smallest thing like comedies
don't have huge inciting incidents
romantic comedies have a breakup or
meeting the other person or you know
whatever it is but whatever that thing
is it's different
because if it's not different why am i
here i don't i'm not here to watch
people's everyday lives i have my own
life i can go watch my friends lives you
know what i mean i'm here because
something is changing for them and i now
need to watch them to struggle through
it grow through it whatever is going to
happen on that journey that's why i'm
here so there has to be an inciting
incident something has to come in and
make change cause problems cause a goal
that needs to be achieved
what is your process for teaching
screenplay structure yeah so
i start with this great the screenplay i
start with the pixar formula
from the pixar formula i go into
character work i am
someone in my own time who likes to
psychoanalyze things i'm always asking
people why how you know what what
happened to you and so we do some work
like that for the characters the more
that you understand uh people the more
you can understand your characters who
are people so in my class which may make
some people uncomfortable but in my
class we talk about ourselves a lot
we're doing a lot of inner work um
because my class is also about
fighting writer's block and in my
opinion writer's block comes from lack
of confidence and lack of preparation so
we spend a lot of time talking about
confidence talking about what our fears
are what our flaws are what our wants
are what's standing in the way of those
wants why because that's what's
happening for your characters what do
they want what do they need what's
standing in the way of that what are
they what are they afraid of what are
their flaws that are going to get in the
way of them getting the thing that they
want right so if you start to understand
how your own life the life of your tribe
members i call my classes tribes the
life of your tribe members um
if you start to understand why they do
the things they do then you start to
understand characters a little bit more
and now your characters can be more
authentic in their journey because
oftentimes i can feel the writer making
characters do things
versus it feeling like an actual
decision that the character would make
so we spend some time on characters
so let's say that's week two that's
actually just what i did on a couple of
days ago week two that was last night it
was just last night
it's hard to keep up with time these
days um it's all one
big thing
then we um start to talk about goal
setting
um because every single story is about
your protagonist solving a problem
reaching a goal that's why we are here
so we have to figure out what's the best
goal for them to reach or who's the best
character for that goal depending upon
which one you begin with um and then we
start talking about now how are they
physically going to achieve it because
again going back to they need to save
the world well that's general
what are they going to do how are they
going to save it and start asking
ourselves well what are the things that
get in the way so in the
uh fourth week we start talking about
the complications we started talking
about the stakes um in in week three we
also talk about world building um
because
every single story
you have to teach us the rules of that
world if it's just regular old
present-day earth something that we see
in the first three minutes are gonna
tell me that that's what it is so you're
still teaching me right if it's um a new
industry like i love to use devil the
devil wears prada right i'm not in the
fashion industry so you have to teach me
how it works here right so they open up
by showing me how all the other women
are nicely dressed and our protagonist
is not right they show us by when she
gets into that office how everyone is
looking at her judging her and then when
meryl streep's character is going to
show up everybody it's chaotic because
they're trying to make sure they get in
line i'm learning about this industry
right i'm learning about what the rules
are here even if there's not much being
said out loud so we talk about that and
especially if you're doing something
that's science fiction fantasy
supernatural horror then there are rules
you have to set up i need to know
candyman comes when i say it how many
times right because if not then i don't
have the suspense
now if i see a person standing in the
mirror and they only say it twice should
i be afraid because i don't know how
many times they're supposed to say it if
i understand they have to say it five
times i don't even remember if it's five
or three but they have to say it x
amount of times and now i know when she
gets on number four
that i should be on the edge of my seat
but i don't know that if you haven't
given me the information
so we talk about world building um and
then in the last week that's when we
finally start talking about outlining
because i want people to know there's
not one way to do it right you can do it
a million different ways so i show them
different examples of how you can
outline but all of those things that
we're learning basically
break into those large beats and let me
be specific about those beats because
i've said them you know said that word a
lot um but i'm talking specifically
about the normal
the inciting incident
the goal or the problem
getting into act two
knowing what your midpoint is knowing
what your rock bottom you know is
knowing what your point of no return is
which some people kind of mix into that
rock bottom midpoint place it basically
just means we get to a place where
something changes so much that our
character has to change tactics that's
just all it means everybody gives it a
different word
right um but then we got to get up to
our climax which is your highest point
when your bad guy is going to meet your
good guy or your character is going to
meet their problem head on and then we
get to come down to the resolution where
we say what have they won because they
you know succeeded or what did they lose
because they didn't yet throughout that
entire journey we were following them
emotionally so even if they didn't
succeed
we still feel satisfaction with the
story so all of those beats
are what i mean when i'm saying
structure
all of those beats fit into your act one
act two and act three and so i utilize
those different weeks to talk about
those different um
elements because they all break into
those big beats
and how can you tell and i realize this
is very specific and we don't have
something to workshop but just vaguely
when someone is really forcing an action
from their character
it can be because
the evidence is just not on the page or
the evidence is on the page and your
character isn't doing what you've told
us that they do
right so if you've said this is a really
shy character every single thing you've
shown us is that they're shy and then on
page 15 they stand on top of a table and
dance
what that's not who you told me this
person was so unless you showed me
something that motivated this
right
then now i know you just needed her on a
table dancing
because of whatever else is going to
happen in the screenplay not because she
would get on that table and dance i see
okay yeah so we're missing what would
ever cause that if this was truly what
the characters would do okay yeah so
we're missing that so either it's just
not there at all or it's the opposite of
what you told us
yeah and so it's like we know that you
needed this character to end up in jail
because
now the sun has to avenge
you know whatever's going on with with
the parent being in jail
but
it isn't set up that our character would
have even done any of those things that
they did to be in jail so now i know
you're just forcing them
into this position
because of what you need to happen from
that so it's like you got to set me up
with the information so i can believe it
because if i don't believe it then now
now the stakes aren't as high you know
now you just start to lose me as a as an
audience member yeah so it's just like i
need the evidence so that's a lot of
what i'll write in my notes i don't
there's no evidence of this this doesn't
ring true you know like where did this
happen when do we meet that well you
said on page this that this is how they
feel but on page this they feel this way
what motivated that change where where
was that
because maybe i missed it i probably
didn't but maybe i missed it
but if i didn't if i didn't miss it then
now you know it's missing and you can
figure out how to make that connection
because everything is cause and effect
people are cause and effect if i have an
argument in this room when i walk into
that room my energy is gonna be
different if i had not had an argument
in this room so the same thing is true
about your characters why are they doing
the stuff that they're doing what
happened on the page
to show me
uh that motivates
any of their decisions
how does a writer introduce a
protagonist in a way that makes
the viewer or the reader want to follow
that character yeah good question i
actually did an entire workshop on how
do i and i call them how the f right all
of my workshops are in the what the f
workshop series so this particular
workshop was how the f do i introduce my
protagonist right and there are a
million ways to do it but what we're
looking for is what information are you
going to give me about them in their
normal life that makes me like them or
relate to them i don't have to do both
it's 20 21 so i don't have to like the
character they can be totally unlikable
but something about them has to be
i have to be able to relate to in order
to care enough and invest in them on
this journey so
um i use the word social proof and
basically what that means is prove to me
going back to the evidence right prove
to me who they are on the page whether
that means we're receiving information
from someone else
or we're watching them do the thing
because just like regular human beings
you can only
take what they say about themselves with
a grain of salt right so i can sit here
and go i'm an expert i'm an expert i'm
an expert but unless you actually hear
me giving my expertise on something or
you hear from someone else who you trust
who says shannon is an expert
then you're probably gonna say i'm not
one so
on the page you have to then show us
that your characters are whoever it is
you want us to believe that they are so
one of my favorite examples is using
scandal right we open up scandal hearing
from two other people talk about olivia
pope
one of them is the trusted source
the other one is the fish out of water
who
already has some kind of admiration for
olivia pope right so as we're hearing
them talk about olivia they're putting
her on this pedestal and now we are
therefore intrigued to go well who's
this olivia i want to know her she seems
cool and then in the next scene olivia
now has to live up to the thing that we
just heard
so now you have to show us
in action they could have gone to the
next scene and olivia was just sitting
there having a meeting talking you know
on the phone to herself but instead they
put her in a situation to show her
social proof and doing her job and so
hearing from those other people first
and then seeing her actually do the
thing is what made us
want to journey with olivia pope so the
same is true for your characters there
is no particular kind of formula but
what i will say is you got about five to
seven minutes
to get me engaged with your protagonist
um some stories won't start with the
protagonist which is fine but that means
if it didn't start with the protagonists
and then we meet them you have less time
to get me to like or relate to them
because i'm already x amount of minutes
into your film so for example i'm
teaching from armageddon right now right
we don't meet harry stamper i think a
snapper until like page 10 which means
we're we've been here for 10 minutes
already
because we got our exciting incident on
page two
so that means the urgency is already
there they're already making up a plan
by the time we meet harry i only get
like three pages to really understand
who he is
and jump into action with him to decide
to invest in him so now you have even
less time because i'm already 10 minutes
into it but either way whatever it is i
see them doing first so you can't be um
generic about that like oftentimes i
will read a screenplay and it's just oh
such and such woman who's beautiful is
cooking breakfast
and it just seems like she's cooking
breakfast because she needs busy work in
the kitchen not because cooking
breakfast teaches us anything about her
right is she cooking breakfast because
she's a stay-at-home mom and she's in
her pajamas and she has to get up early
even though she's going to be at home
but because she's got to get husband out
she's got to get kids out and she's
getting it done or is she career woman
who's cooking breakfast so she doesn't
really have much time because she's on
the phone at the same time she's just
trying to get something in and it's a
smoothie and she's running out or is
this saturday the only day that she gets
to you know relax and she's making
brunch because her girlfriends are
coming over like what does it mean and
what am i learning about this person as
they're cooking eggs because if not they
could be doing something else you know
what i mean so every single piece of
information that i get in those first
five to seven minutes are gonna help me
know who they are and that's prime real
estate and a lot of people
pass right through that prime real
estate by doing the uncle such and such
thing
talking about all this other stuff that
does not matter meanwhile all i got
about my protagonist was beautiful in
cooking eggs
why am i investing in her you know what
how is that interesting why would any
actor who reads it say i gotta play her
right so you're trying to give me some
information that's gonna give me a
reason to invest in the rest of their
journey and you only get a very short
amount of time
okay so if something doesn't happen
within a five to seven minute minute
mark to show me why i should care about
the scene
so then if we have this woman
cooking these eggs and then maybe
there's a knock at the door and it's um
you know some door-to-door
salesman so we think
and it turns out it's really a private
investigator and they're
saying you know i have something for you
and her life is about to change in that
moment and she finds out that her life
and what she thought it was wasn't
really that but we don't know in that
moment so everything seems calm and
wonderful and you know she's beautiful
and she has this nice kitchen but then
the knock at the door is going to be
what's going to upset the apple cart yes
but i want to make sure that we separate
the two things right that that upset of
the apple cart can happen 15 pages in it
can happen 17 pages in
everything that i'm getting up until
that upset
is what's making me invest in her
why do i care that her life is going to
change if i haven't learned anything
about her life other than the fact that
she cooks eggs
right
what information are you gonna give me
does she have a child that she's caring
for um that they have a really great
relationship with does she have a
husband that she has a bad relationship
with and she's just today's the day
they're supposed to go to therap therapy
and she just really wants it to go well
and then this thing comes in and
interrupts that right so what
information am i getting about this
person's everyday life that's already
worth investing in so that when the
upset comes i too can be upset
like no she really needs to go to
therapy today she doesn't have time to
deal with this door-to-door guy you know
or no her sleeping child is in the other
room and she tried so hard to have
children and she finally has one and
then here comes this person and are they
posing a threat to the child that's in
the other room right and again none of
this has anything to do with eggs so the
question is do we need to open with her
cooking eggs like what does that mean
for her as a character or maybe it means
everything because she's really a chef
in another life but because she decided
to be a stay-at-home mom you know blah
blah blah or maybe it means i'm always
going to make sure my husband's eggs are
great
we argue every morning but these eggs
matter today because we have therapy
later and i want him to be happy when he
gets to therapy right now all of that
stuff is making me invest in her so when
the person comes and knocks on the door
i understand no no no we don't need this
interruption like we don't need this to
happen
how can you explain smart goals for your
protagonist yeah good question so i
actually do a series called story
elements on my youtube channel and one
of them is on goals and i talk about
smart goals so smart goals is an acronym
for specific
measurable
attainable
relevant and time-bound okay right and
smart goals actually was not uh created
for story but it works so i have adapted
it from like a business model
to use it to teach my students how to
make goals for their protagonists so
specific means we need to know what it
is
period we need to know
what they're trying to achieve so that
we can track the progress or regress of
it
how will we know that they were
successful if we don't know what they
were looking for in the first place
right so your goal needs to be specific
the second one is measurable so that
again goes back to being able to track
it right we need to know are they
getting closer to it or farther from it
which is why i always talk about your
external goal being the personification
of the internal goal so if someone's
goal is to not grieve anymore how do i
track that what does that look like and
if you can
attach grieving to something external or
not grieving to something external then
we'll know that when they reach that
external thing then they reach the goal
and their grief has probably subsided
the third one is attainable
which means going back to social proof
you have to prove to me that my
protagonist has the skills to be able to
attain this goal
because if not then i'm not going to
believe that they can do it right or if
it's a comedy then you're going to show
me that they don't have the skills to
attain this goal which means they're
either going to do a really bad job of
it or they're going to have to learn
along the way right or even in a drama i
don't have those skills so i have to
learn
those skills along the way and so now
it's probably going to be during your
debate time or somewhere in your journey
in your second act where they actually
have to learn those skills
the fourth one is relevant and i like
this one because this one kind of starts
to attach that internal thing to the
external thing it's like why does this
thing matter to this particular
protagonist so that goes back to
choosing the right protagonist for the
right goal
having the right goal for the right
protagonist so if you can make it
relevant then we will invest more we
will empathize more and the last one is
time-bound and not every single story is
going to have something time-bound but
it's basically your ticking clock right
if this if there's a state of urgency if
like an armageddon you have 18 days
before the world explodes
then we understand that suspense is that
tension is going to stay there it's like
oh my god we only have 18 days and now
we have 12 and now we have 50 you know
however many days so adding a ticking
clock depending upon your story will
always heighten the stakes
so
if nothing else you need specific
measurable attainable and relevant and
depending upon what your story is you
can then add a ticking clock
how else can i write a three-dimensional
character good question so
getting into the stuff of the character
is where that dimension is going to come
from people are complex we're not all
good we're not all bad we all have wants
we all have needs we all have flaws we
all have skills even before the inciting
incident happens so if you can figure
out what those things are then you will
figure out what's motivating your
character right i gave this example that
i am the youngest of six girls
but the closest one in age to me is six
years older than i am which would mean
that at age six she's 12. we don't play
the same right so we're not interacting
in the same way when i'm 12 she's 18. we
don't play the same so we're not
interacting in the same way because
she's 18 she's graduating from high
school so now i'm in at home by myself
for another six years so even though i
have five older siblings i spent a lot
of time alone
so therefore i have an only child kind
of experience just as much as i have a
youngest child experience
that shows up in my life
i am an introverted extrovert a lot of
people know me as the life of a party i
have a big personality but i love being
alone
i problem solve alone i do a lot of
stuff by myself because my history
taught me to be able to be okay with
that right good or bad so understanding
those things about your characters will
let you know why they do the things they
do so there may be people who say well
shannon well why didn't you call me on
saturday we could have hung out because
they don't understand that shannon just
likes to sit at home and
be by herself because she's used to that
that person may take it personally you
know oh well that's an offense towards
me you don't think that we're really
good friends and blah blah blah blah but
it's like no it really has nothing to do
with you and everything to do with me
and the same thing is true for your
characters they are acting and reacting
because of who they are where they're
from an immigrant is not having the same
experience in america as an american
born person
period if you know that depending upon
the kind of story you're telling you can
now infuse your story with that stuff
the same thing is culturally as a black
person there are things that are going
to happen in my house that may not
happen in someone else's right so you
have to then take that and figure out
how you can color in the lines of your
story with this cultural stuff that
makes it authentic for them but the only
way you can do that is if you really
take the time out to know who your
characters are and know why they're
making the decisions they're making and
now you can get three-dimensional people
the other thing is it's 2021 so we're
now doing the same thing for our
antagonist right our antagonists get to
be three-dimensional now you know we're
no longer in the jack nicholson
joker time we're in the heath ledger and
the joaquin phoenix you know uh joker
time we're in the killmonger time where
we understand our antagonists just as
much as we understand our protagonists
which leaves us as an audience fighting
with those themes and trying to figure
out who's right and who's wrong and now
there's discussion happening when people
go home but that only happens when you
take the time to dimensionalize your
antagonist understand what their plan is
understand what they want what motivates
them right which is usually the opposite
of your protagonist or the same right
like if it's a sports movie it's the
same we both want to win right if it's
um
you know uh some kind of action film
then it's usually the opposite the
antagonist wants to kill people the
protagonist doesn't want them to those
are the reasons that they are in
competition with each other and i've
said before if we change the pov of the
story then your antagonist should easily
become your protagonist right your
protagonist is the antagonist antagonist
because that antagonist does not exist
because your protagonists exist that was
already a person who was already
planning to kill people
you came in and became a complication
for that person they didn't start
killing people because you exist they
were already a murderer and as a police
officer you came in and you you know
decided to uh to muddy it up so if we
were telling the story from the killer's
point of view
then now that would be our protagonist
right and they'd both be dimensionalized
enough to put us in the middle of it
right because they're stories about
vigilantes they're murderers
but they're doing it for a reason we
understand their reasoning and sometimes
we're on their side for it right so if
you give us uh if you do the work
because some of that work you're gonna
do is not gonna end up on the page but
it's still going to
um dictate some of the uh choices you
make for those characters on the page
what are the elements of story that have
to happen in act two oh good question so
in act 2 some people call this the fun
and games place
i call it the trial and error place i
look at it like this is your recipe this
is your i want to bake a cake
how
step one
do this step two
do this right so in act two we're
actually watching the character
try to achieve the goal
successfully or unsuccessfully
um so
being able to see them actually take
physical steps towards doing that thing
is what we're watching
now we're going to start putting in the
complications and i like to call it
complications and not conflict because
people see conflict and they go just add
some negative something right
but a complication is something that's
very specific to stand in the way of the
goal
right so they're going to start coming
in contact with things that are
hindering them from getting what they
need things that are redirecting them
things that are causing them to hit rock
bottom
and then you need a midpoint and your
midpoint sounds like what it is right
happens kind of in the middle of your
story doesn't have to literally be on
page 45 of the 90 pages but it's gonna
happen somewhere around there and it
basically means that something big
enough happens to cause that redirection
either i'm gonna hit rock bottom or i
have a false victory or
um i receive some information that
changes my goal so i believe i gave this
example i've given this example before
because it's the easiest one for me if
my goal was to find my kidnapped child
at the midpoint i'd find out that my
kidnapped child has already been killed
right
that doesn't mean the story is over
though because we're only at the
midpoint that means my my goal has to
change
so now my goal is not to find my child
my goal is to
find the killer
to get revenge to get justice and so for
the rest of the screenplay we're gonna
watch the uh the parent do that
right instead of looking after the child
so the goal changes something causes a
redirection um and then some people look
at the climax as what happens at the end
of act two some people look at it as
what happens at the beginning of act
three either way it's in the same place
in my opinion so you're also going to be
getting your um
character up to the point where they
actually are face to face with that goal
or face to face with that antagonist so
they can win or lose so those are the
biggest beats they need that trial and
error time or fun and games time or you
know steps to their recipe time they
need those complications that get in the
way of that so they can grow so they can
redirect they need that big moment
whatever that midpoint is that
causes a new goal makes them redirect
makes them hit rock bottom so someone
has to come in and re-motivate them
right now your mentor character gets to
come in and give a speech or whatever
and keep get them going uh if you're
watching an episode of grey's anatomy
that's the moment where it's like i
found the new cure right at first we
thought we'd never be able to do this
surgery oh no we didn't do well
i found this new thing and now for the
rest of the episode they're gonna do the
new thing until they win or lose or save
the patient or not save the patient and
then you'll go up to the climax which is
where they save the patient or not save
the patient so those are the beats that
you're looking for in act two
so if we used our pam from the office
and so she's at home doing the zoom
she's already now met this woman at a
store who says email me i've got this
really cool job if you want to make some
extra money
and
pam is already doing the job by act two
maybe okay it depends on what the goal
of the episode is so if we're looking at
meeting this woman as the inciting
incident
the problem can be deciding to call her
or not
um and if that's the pro if that's the
goal deciding to call her then the
journey is going to be the decision
now she's going to have to i don't know
what she's doing to figure out whether
she should make this call or not but
that may mean that everything we're
watching in her normal every day is
telling her i need a change i need a new
thing that motivates the call because it
can be the end of the episode where she
finally makes the call
or
it could be that i already know i'm
gonna call i've said i was gonna call so
that means we're gonna watch her call
we're going to watch her get set up with
the new job we're going to watch her do
all of that in the second act where she
figures out what it is um and then again
seeing how that may cause friction with
her current job so it really again is
always going to depend on what's the
intended goal is is the pilot let's say
this is her this is the pilot is the
pilot about her choosing to go into this
nefarious work or is the pilot about i
admit it
what are the repercussions of it
okay so something would have to happen
so let's say so and the stuff that was
happening for her to decide what
happened in act one
no that's going to be act two okay and
only because we're talking about
television now and television um if it's
uh
in television we need that inciting
incident by the end of act one so now
your act two is gonna be all the stuff
that yeah i decided to take the job i
didn't decide to take the job this is
why this is what's happening with my
other job and then in act three you
resolve and and depending upon what the
goal was um if she's choosing to take
the job then in act three we finally
hear her say i'm gonna take the job
if it was no i've chosen this job and
the problem is trying to balance then by
the end of act three we'll know what the
rest of the season is going to look like
because we just saw how this balance
works or doesn't work or maybe she
didn't find out that it was nefarious
until the climax of the episode so in
act 3 she has to decide to continue even
though she knows that it's nefarious so
it can go a million ways but basically
whatever that goal is that we get by the
end of act one when that inciting
incident happens she meets pam at the
end of act one pam says call me
and act two we're gonna either see her
call and then get on board it or decide
to call which means now we have to see
well what motivates that because if this
is so far out of her life she would
never do something like this then that
means whatever's happening during this
day
in this episode is the stuff that's
pushing her to finally make the call
okay so maybe she gets a text in the
middle of the night and it's urgent and
they've got to fax something overseas
and hey i'm really sorry to bother you i
know you're sleeping but this needs to
happen asap and then maybe she sees the
webcam light come on on her work
computer and she realizes there's like
um some type of a snooping software and
it's recording her and and it knows that
she took like a 10 minute walk around
the block and she wasn't at her computer
and so she's now feeling
trapped by this job
and she says okay
i might email this interesting lady and
the interesting lady gets back to her
like midnight
hey here it is and this is what you do
here's a link
and she goes maybe she has a glass of
wine and she decides to apply for the
job
and now
she's giving reviews on lingerie it's
not horrible it's like something where
yeah because you know if we're saying
that it's in the tone of the office and
that means it's a half hour single
camera so it's going to be you know kind
of like kind of funny may have you know
small things happen here and there that
could be a little darker right um but
that means we're talking about three act
structure and we're talking about half
hours so we don't have a lot of time so
it can be something that simple that you
know i got back i got this card oh i'd
never do that and now i'm sleeping and
enjoying myself and here come these
people saying they need this facts and
this thing and that thing and i just
want something new
all right i'll make the call let's do
something new okay
and so and then in act three
something entirely different is going to
happen possibly depending upon what
happened in your act two since it's all
cause and effect but because we're
talking about television
and because we're talking about the
pilot by the time we get to the end of
act three we need to understand what the
series is about so we need to know that
she has decided to do this
and
either we already know it's nefarious or
we don't so that's what we're gonna find
out in the series or
um we realize it's getting in the way of
her current job and so we're going to
watch her try to balance it throughout
right um so we'll we'll need that
information so sometimes in pilots uh
usually when it's kind of like a
whodunit kind of thing
and a half hour single camera comedy um
they usually tie up things with a pretty
decent bow at the end of the episodes
right but if we're talking about
one-hour dramas if we're talking about a
whodunit kind of limited series thing
then at the end of every episode you're
going to give me some new information so
yes something new is going to happen so
that i'll come back to the next episode
and that new information might be it
wasn't who you thought it was you know
or this is a new person's doing
something sneaky or whatever it is yeah
what mistakes do writers make in act 2
that end up ruining their screenplay
yeah this is where you know they don't
know structure
this is where you know they haven't
figured out what their story was before
they got to the page because this is
where uncle such and such shows up
this is where
this is the goal
this is the story and the writer is
doing this
because they don't know what the goal or
the story is or they don't know how to
get to z from a
um
and you know maybe it's because they're
just a new writer so they really just
don't know how or they don't understand
structure so they're doing all of these
other things to get to z but none of
those things connect going back to cause
and effect none of those things connect
so that happens quite often and i think
that's the biggest thing um sometimes
there is no midpoint
um and you know depending upon what kind
of story it is what the tone is what the
genre is the midpoint doesn't have to be
something huge but it's you know bigger
than your other trials and tribulations
um so sometimes people are missing that
thing that gets us over the hump because
once we get into act two and you get
into those those trials and tribulations
if it's
uh take a step fail take a step fail
take a step fail by the time they're
doing that the fourth time i'm no longer
invested
you know what i mean i need something
that's going to change this thing to get
us going in the story so it goes back to
you know having that friend or cousin
who's really great at telling stories
right they know how to hook us in make
us think that this one thing is
happening and then take us to the next
thing right so that midpoint kind of
gets us over that hump of they've been
trying and failing or trying and
succeeding and here's something that's
going to change this whole thing for us
so that the pacing can kind of start to
rev up and we can get to the climax um
so a lot of times that's missing also
the climax is missing but more so in
television pilots that i read than in
features it seems like future writers
kind of understand a little bit more
that there needs to be this high point
in tv because people are thinking about
the series and if you're writing a pilot
then you're you know creating a world
and characters that people can be
invested in they sometimes forget about
the structure of it and forget that yeah
but we're still telling a story so i
need them i need we got to get up
right and so a lot of times that's
missing and so if you're writing um a
half hour single camera comedy that
means or a dramedy then you have three
acts so your climax is gonna happen at
the end of act uh two or at the top of
act three depending upon how you write
it if you're doing a one hour drama and
let's just stay in the five act place
because there's a four act that exists
in the six act whatever let's stay in
the five act place then it's going to
happen at the end of act four or top of
act five depending upon how you write it
so a lot of the times in tv there's just
it never makes it
to a peak it just kind of stays here the
whole time and no matter what stories
you're telling pilots features uh even
if you're writing a spec and you're
doing an episode of something we're
looking for stories to do this we're on
a roller coaster so we don't want to
spend our whole time like this we don't
want to spend our whole time like this
we don't want to spend the whole time
like that we have to have all of it
happening if not it's not a fun ride and
no one wants to get on it
and so uncle gus's method would be he
would just be
telling too much sort of sidebar detail
that we don't need whereas the other
person at the let's say the family
barbecue they have like a a b and c a
very clear point very clear points
very clear path and by the time uncle
you know gus is done and you ask uncle
gus so what happened he probably
wouldn't even tell you the same story if
you asked again right because he's just
talking about everything and doesn't
know you know his his point his end goal
right or he gets to the end goal but
we're all lost because none of the stuff
between when he started in the end goal
made any sense because they're not
connected everything has to be connected
right and the other cousin knows how to
make a connect to b connect to c connect
to d uncle gus is saying a g
you know e m and it's like wait but what
happened to b and c and d you know i got
missing something like give me this
other information and he's cracking
himself up no one else is laughing
because we missed the joke you know what
i mean yes that kind of stuff that
starts happening
do writers get confused with subplot
versus plot how do we know the
difference yeah i'm going to assume that
if you're saying subplot that you mean
different story lines and that's the way
that i kind of like to talk about it and
i don't think i've seen too many people
get confused with it but
not really knowing how to use them and
make them impactful for each other so
when i describe sub characters i
describe them as characters who are
helping or hindering the protagonist's
goal
we only care about these sub characters
because they are pushing the a story
forward
that doesn't mean that those characters
don't also have their own storylines
because they're people and they should
be doing things other than walking
around behind your protagonist all day
right however
the point of their stories is to
eventually crash into the a story
eventually complicate the a story
eventually help the a story even if they
look like they're going this for this
way at some point
they're gonna you know connect and so i
think some people miss that and they
will then start to write an entirely
different story
for the b story that has absolutely
nothing to do with the a story and now
we're watching these two stories go but
they're not connected right so going
back to our family reunion if i were to
come to your family reunion i expect to
meet your cousins
not your neighbor's cousins
so those sub characters are here because
they're important to this protagonist
they're not other random people in the
world
those random people weren't invited to
the barbecue right the people who are
here the people who are
um helping or hurting
informing helping complicating what's
going on with the protagonists so we
only care about them because of their
proxy you know their proximity to the
protagonist so i think people don't
understand that and they just say oh
my subplot or my b story is just another
story it's like no thematically they tie
plot wise they tie something about them
connects them all and a great example of
that is crash the crash right because
there are 50 million main characters but
they're all dealing with the same kind
of themes
and they all eventually
connect
right so spoiler alert they all
eventually get you to this dead kid who
is the brother of one of those people
who was killed by one of the other
people right so it all starts to connect
when we first start to watch it we're
like why do we need to be following all
these people what is what is going on
but it's because
their world is smaller than we think it
is they are all in the same world and
they will all
affect that a story so in that
particular film haven't seen it in a
little while but i wouldn't say there's
a standout protagonist unless we'll say
it's don cheadle's character who is the
detective maybe but instead it seems
like we just have a lot of main
characters and they each have their own
story lines right but the a plot is what
happened to this
this boy because we open up with
learning that someone died
um so the main plot is what happened to
this boy and then we go into all of
these other stories to eventually come
back to oh that's what happened but then
beyond that um
the themes are about how we're all just
people regardless of our differences so
it talks a lot about race and religion
and all these other things so each of
those groups of people is dealing with
that theme on their own level so that
still connects them they're they're not
random stories that are being told
they're all connected so if people can
understand that about subplot or like i
like to call them story lines or a story
b story c story e d story however many
story lines you're going to have they
all have to connect and they all have to
push your a story forward even if when
they first start it seems like it has
nothing to do with that eventually it
all has to come back to this one thing
or at least thematically tie and the
theme is usually again going to be shown
in your a story so that means all of the
other storylines are still going to
thematically tie into them
well let's take this family barbecue
so let's say everybody's happy
everything's wonderful
and then there's another scene where
there's a man and maybe a beat-up
vehicle
who's delivering something and it's his
personal vehicle and he's stressing out
he's in traffic and you know people are
cutting him off whatever and he's trying
to be a decent driver but he finally
gets there and he's sweating and he
unloads this cake for this barbecue
and
when he delivers it
he finds out that one of the children
there that's actually his kid
and the wife and he had been estranged
for years
and now
this happy moment
is awful because all the memories have
come back and he hasn't seen the sun in
years because it was too it was too
difficult yeah and so now he's this
subplot has now come into the main plot
exactly okay
okay
and so then
how so then how long does this sub
character stay
at that barbecue yeah it depends on your
story going back to
what's the goal
is the goal for
him to
[Music]
have the realization of this was my
family because if so then that's the end
of the movie
everything got us to the moment that he
arrived right
if the story is about
working on getting my family back or
working on rekindling with my son or you
know whatever that was then it could be
the inciting incident that he shows up
with the cake it could be the midpoint
that he shows up with the cake right so
we've been seeing him he had his goal i
need to deliver this cake
we're watching up until the midpoint
everything that he's trying to do to
deliver the cake i don't know what's
happening with the other family but they
have their own goals and whatever
they're doing preparing for the barbecue
whatever they're doing right or
attending the barbecue and dealing with
family drama because they're already
talking about
her ex-husband and blah blah blah you
know that kind of thing um
so when he shows up at the midpoint
now things are redirected right so
what's happening for the rest of the
time is it stay here and work it out
because this is the scene right it's
it's pandemic so people aren't doing a
lot of different locations and blah blah
blah so do we stay here and work out the
whole thing
or
does that end the barbecue scene and now
we go into the rest of life
as he's trying to rekindle the
relationship so depending upon what that
goal is then you know how long this
barbecue thing needs to happen or this
journey to the barbecue in the first
place and then what scenes we need after
that for him to actually reach his goal
and if you've done your work of making
the goal relevant
while he's preparing this cake while
he's driving through traffic while he's
doing blah blah blah we will learn that
there is a loneliness there we will
learn that there is a
like maybe we don't get want to give it
away that he lost his child you know
whatever that stuff is but we're getting
some information to know
that there's something he's missing
something that he's needing something
he's given up on maybe it's because
people are calling as he's driving and
he's i don't want to talk about it man
you know blah blah whatever that is
we'll start to know something else is
going on here so that when he arrives
with that cake and he gets out of the
car and stops short yeah
no one has to say anything right we know
because we've been given the evidence
that something's going on with him and
we've been given the evidence at the
barbecue as she's been setting up and oh
he's of this and he's that and we've
been hearing
the stuff it hasn't been like you know
the a story because it wasn't yet but
now that these two things have collided
they'll make one storyline and we'll go
on from there
how many subplots should a movie have or
a tv show have yeah so there isn't
necessarily a set amount but what i will
say is
your a story is going to be in every
single one of your acts
fully out
some
movies will only have an a story
um
if you have a b story it's now still all
of the same amount of beats
but shorter
right so if your a story is this long
your b story might be that long
your c story and d story and e story all
get shorter but they're still full story
lines which means they have their own
goals their own complications climaxes
etc
in a television show you're usually only
gonna have maybe about three
per episode even if you have
six or seven characters like if you
watch this is us
something's gonna be going on with one
of the big three something's gonna be
going on with mom and dad in the past
and then we may also be watching
something else maybe
um in a show like brothers and sisters
there were five kids and a mom so maybe
we're definitely gonna have at least
three story lines but there might be a
fourth small nugget of something that's
giving us breadcrumbs from something
bigger that's going to happen you know
down the road
what i will say is in features it's good
to have at least more than one storyline
depending on the genre most horror
movies have one storyline stay alive
protagonist
that's it they're also usually only 75
minutes long so we don't really have
time to be following up and other people
and whatever else is going on we're just
trying to stay in this one little thing
but other than that um it's good to have
a b story because you want to break up
the monotony of the a story because
again once we get into the second act
it's about reaching that goal and if i'm
just if every single page is about what
this one person is doing
that can become monotonous right it
becomes like get there or don't get
there you know we start to get a little
impatient so if you have something to
break it up with another storyline
another full story line then that can
kind of help
keep the uh pacing up you know i've seen
it a lot in love stories a lot of love
stories will just have the love
but how much can we take uh together not
together together not together together
not together it's like do they have
anything else that they can be doing you
know like what's going on in their
personal lives that can be a b and a c
story you know what i mean what's going
on with mom that that can thematically
tie to what's happening with them that
we can be watching because if not then
we can start to get disinterested by the
redundancy because it's a relationship
how much can they really go through even
if it's a new piece of conflict it still
ends in the same thing be together or
don't right so if we keep watching them
do this
for 40 minutes i mean that we need to
break that up a little bit so it's
always good to have another
but in general there isn't a standard i
think that
you can figure out if you if you've um
gotten too many of them if things start
to get a little messy and you can't
really follow
the story lines um
like even if you look at a marvel film
uh at the avengers right the avengers
has all of the peop all of the
superheroes there but we're not
following each of them separately in all
the things that they're doing right we
may be following them as a group and
then following one or two of them who
may be doing something separately and
the others are just there for support in
this particular movie and that's okay so
you want to definitely make sure that it
doesn't become too much like if you look
at um at crash that was i don't know how
many people that was but there was a lot
of story lines but they were simple
enough
right simple
and thematic so each time we came to
them we were kind of mirroring whatever
just happened with the other group of
people on their side of town or getting
them closer to meeting one of the other
group of people so it worked for them so
that's why again it's everything is
going to come down to what's best for
your story so you have to be paying
attention to that pacing and am i
spending enough time to understand what
the storyline is or am i just dropping a
couple of people every now and again
which now confuses us so instead of it
breaking up the monotony it's confusing
us and we have more questions so you
just have to again find another pair of
eyes if you can't figure it out right
hire a script consultant like myself
there are plenty of us out there or have
someone who understands story at least
to read it to see how it's making them
feel and what information they're
missing
so with this family barbecue story if we
have this dad that's now bringing this
cake
and now the rest of the family is just
stunned that he's doing this job and
that he's there and that he's actually
shown himself
you know maybe there were calls that say
don't come by anymore who knows what
happened
if we were to add another character it
would somehow have to make it in
it can't just be the random guy at the
bar that he goes
pounds a drink and he goes hey man slow
down what's wrong and oh you know i
can't talk about it somehow that guy at
the bar has to be part of the story
he can't just be i mean again
every sub-character has
their own role to play
meeting a guy in a bar doesn't have to
become a storyline okay that
sub-character can just be the person in
the bar that had some kind of
conversation with our actual character
that motivated or changed them to go do
something
right okay so that person doesn't have
to become a storyline that person can
just be a guy in the bar who said
whatever but whatever it is he said had
to have changed our character because if
not then we don't need this conversation
we don't need this bar we don't need
this location we need to pay for these
people
or any of that right right okay so that
so that's going to be the difference but
if i watched guy at bar at home and then
watch guy at bar get to the bar then i
watch guy at bar drive away from the bar
then now i'm asking myself okay what
does this guy bar have to do with any of
this right because now i'm watching
their life from their point of view
so
does guy from barr end up being her new
boyfriend
right
so he didn't know that when they were
sitting next to each other these two men
when they're talking about the situation
and gaia bar is like you should go get
your family back
right and now guy with cake shows up at
the barbecue and then guy with bar a guy
from the bar drives up what are you
doing here getting my family back
oh that's my girl now
we've got something going on now these
story lines are connecting
i was actually thinking that the guy at
the bar would be a negative
reflection of the of the protagonist
that he didn't want to ever become and
so he sees himself in that guy at the
bar and he go and the guy at the bar is
drunk and he's like yeah my ex-wife
she's a you-know-what and you know i
just you know whatever i i i walked out
a long time ago
and and hey johnny give me another
bourbon or whatever and then
he sees like i could become that man and
i don't want to be that and that
straightens him out yep and that so in
that case then he's just a sub character
okay he doesn't have his own storyline
okay so he's not a subplot story yeah
he's not a subplot he's just a sub
character he's just a character who's
helping to push the story forward by his
interaction with this guy but a story
line would mean that the guy at the bar
has his own goals and we're following
him trying to achieve those goals too
and then eventually they align with what
everybody else has going on i see okay
so he's a catalyst
okay yeah interesting just coming in to
push you in one direction or the other
because again if not then we don't need
him
right we don't need a guy who's just at
the bar being belligerent
that that belligerence should
affect our guy in some kind of way
because if not then we don't need that